ich bin bei ihr team thomas das sind ja
rührende szenen die sich in diesem jahr
abspielen wir sehen hier an einer brücke
ja was mit dem film engine die gerade
aus dieser stadt gekommen sind und jetzt
sozusagen wieder in sicherheit sind
zumindest in der scheinbaren sicherheit
denn natürlich kann auch hier jederzeit
eine rakete ein treffen das ist
sozusagen der weg richtung ihr team nur
drei kilometer ungefähr von hier drei
bis vier kilometer da geht es auf diesem
platz und das verdient schlacht das
waren die bilder die ihr gesehen habt
vorhin wo diese rakete eingeschlagen ist
wo zivilisten ums leben gekommen sind
auch gerade eben haben sich hier
dramatische szenen abgespielt menschen
werden hier in bussen rausgebracht aus
dieser stadt aus diesem vorort von tier
und eine ältere frau ist neben mir
zusammengebrochen
sie konnte sich kaum noch halten tränen
die menschen stammten waren da teilweise
tagelang eingeschlossenen dieser stadt
die ganze zeit artillerie und raketen
alarm das ja ist etwas was menschen
glaube ich kaum aushalten können wir
sehen wie teilweise von der seite immer
wieder musste hier reinkommen und
verschiedene korridore offen sind
tatsächlich zum zeitpunkt jetzt um
menschen zu evakuieren
die bilder die gehen wirklich ans herz
paul die schlinge zieht sich zu auch um
kerstin ist ein vorort von kiew was ist
denn die taktik von wladimir putin was
steckt dahinter
also wir gehen davon aus dass lade mir
gut ihnen weiterhin versucht hierbei
einzukesseln das war sein ziel so sagen
so sagt die ukrainische regierung von
beginn an und sozusagen die wege
abzuschneiden das ist keine versorgung
werden kommt keine lebensmittel keine
medizin und dass man dann ja die
grausame methode sozusagen die
bevölkerung aus rum hat beziehungsweise
so lange druck macht dass der
ukrainische präsident aufgibt und wir
sehen dass es teilweise diese
schockwellen natürlich gibt er versucht
sozusagen oral zu brechen an der
israelischen militär sondern auch der
vielen zivilisten in bereit sind ihre
stadt zu verteilen aber durch diese
kriegstaktik villa siebel gemacht paul
du hast die humanitären korridore
angesprochen ordner bitte doch für uns
noch mal ein was das bedeutet
wir sehen jetzt hier hinter mir zum
beispiel wie einer der busse rauskommt
gehören im hintergrund auch artillerie
ein bisschen weiter weg und mit diesen
bussen klären jetzt die leute hier raus
gebracht
wir gehen vielleicht einfach mal in
diese richtung und schauen
wir gehen einfach mal an ich zeige euch
das einfach mal hier wie es hier
aussieht also das sind die busse die
hier ankommen und da von hier werden die
menschen weiter gebracht danach tier und
ist teilweise
wir fahren im hintergrund einschläge ich
weiß nicht ob ihr sein können aber wir
sehen hier völlig erschöpfte menschen
die ihre habseligkeiten mitgebracht
haben und
vielleicht können wir hier einmal ein
film von hier weiter gebracht werden
nachts ihr zusammengekauert in diesem
bus menschen die gerade aus eppingen
gekommen sind
allerdings beginne
es kann
situationen
es ist halle sagt der kann dies
crossover
also russische panzer in der nähe der
zivilen häuser
als pfand gestoppt
und haben
als er sagt die greifen die russische
armee greift zivilisten an nur was wir
gehen hier einmal durch diesen bus um zu
zeigen welche menschen herausgekommen
sind aus athen das sind die überlebenden
aus
mini jetzt wer sagt wir müssen diesen
wir müssen endlich diesen den luftraum
schließen damit die menschen raus kommen
hollandaise pr
inside.com begonnen wie lange war es
sonnig
das läuft
bis 12 tage bomben und wie herbie große
bombe
im haus gehen will ist ich hab auch
ausnahmen sein haus ist vollkommen
zerstört zu ios ist
also aus
das haus sieht aus wie kann ein großes
hochhaus 88 stockwerke hoch komplett
zerstört hier ist eine ruhe eine
traurige angespannte ruhe in diesem bus
kaum jemand redet die menschen sind
völlig erschöpft
und das sind die gesichter von menschen
die alles verloren haben und jetzt nicht
wissen wo sie hin sollen
und deswegen zu groß es gibt ein großes
problem ist sagt er dass die russische
flieger die russische liga die reiter
jets an ein großes problem darstellen
für die ukraine und dieser mann
appelliert an die westliche welt den
luftraum zu schließen also eine
flugverbotszone durchzusetzen
das was auch bloße lenski gesagt hat
aber was von der nato weiterhin
abgelehnt wird das sind die bilder hier
aus ihr team wir gehen weiter
was machen diese menschen jetzt
die werden wahrscheinlich
nicht seinen frau zu finden sie schon
vor vier tagen aus ihr raus gegangen
sie ist irgendwo bei tschernobyl aber er
hatte bislang kein kontakt mit so
einfach aussieht wie man in italien
situation in zeitnot
gar kein internet keine telefonie das
ist die situation und ist schelling
also funktioniert dieser humanitären
korridor
mit
spots heute hat er die chance
rauszugehen und hat dann diese situation
benutzt das ist auch die probably
posters fällt also die chance ist
wahrscheinlich nutze wenige wenige
stunden ja was
mich zeigen noch einmal hier
wie es weiter in diesem bus aussieht
diese menschen werden jetzt nach kiew
gebracht und dann von da geht es weiter
für viele wahrscheinlich weiter in die
in weiter richtung westen oder zum zu
der zugstation
die menschen denn hier findet brauchen
wasser brauchen medizin müssen versorgt
werden er sagt dort ist alles
zusammengebrochen